ja das ist das Thema Zwang zur Abgabe
der grundsteuererklärungen das ist jetzt
ein Thema
das könnte man als exotenthema abtun hat
auch nichts zu tun mit den anderen
Themen Migration und work kommen wir
auch noch drauf aber es betrifft
trotzdem Dutzende von Millionen Menschen
in Deutschland und ich bin auch der
Bild-Zeitung dankbar dass das immer
wieder schon im Blatt aufgegriffen
worden ist der Zwangsabgabe von
grundsteuererklärungen für 36 Millionen
angeblich das ist die offizielle Zahl
Grundstücke das heißt nicht dass man so
viele Erklärungen abgeben muss weil für
man kann ja wenn es wirtschaftliche
Einheiten sind eine Erklärung dann für
fünf oder zehn Flurstück Nummern abgeben
aber der Bürokratismus
diese Zumutung die Millionen von
Betroffenen ich schätze mal das sind
bestimmt in Deutschland zu 30 Millionen
25 Millionen werden das sein
was man hier zumutet ist ein Skandal
jetzt habe ich hier mein mitgebracht die
ganzen Formulare im Freistaat Bayern
jetzt ist in Bayern das angeblich noch
relativ einfach
das Grundlagen Formular dann gibt's
natürlich massenhaft Anlagen an Anlage
Grundstück Anlage für Landwirte
Tierbestand Anlage Land und
Forstwirtschaft wobei der Tierbestand
wieder normal Anlage zur dieser Anlage
ist und Anlage Anlage und dann wird es
aber dann wird es aber richtig
interessant zu jedem dieser Formular
gibt es dann Anleitungen es gibt
zehn Seiten eng bedruckte Anleitung zum
grundformular Ausfüllen es gibt 10
Seiten an einer Anleitung zur Anlage
Land und Forstwirtschaft es gibt Seiten
Anlage Tierbestand es gibt sieben
seitenanlage Grundstück also das sind
die
Anleitungen zur Anlage also schlimmer
will ich gar nicht mehr von mir
ein paar Grundstücke wieder
inzwischen ziemlich Experte geworden ich
habe nämlich den Selbstversuch gemacht
ich habe mir immer in meinem politischen
Leben angewandt das was wir als
politikerzimmer wieder beim Thema
Bodenhaftung oder reales Leben alles was
wir als Politiker den Menschen zumuten
den Bürgerinnen und Bürgern am besten an
sich selber mal auszuprobieren wie wird
das wie geht es und ich habe mir auch
einen Grundsatz gemacht was ich
niemanden mehr in meiner Bürgerschaft in
meinem Wahlkreis erklären kann in der
Öffentlichkeit dann mache ich politisch
auch nicht mit so und das ist so ein
Beispiel
der Selbstversuch alles probiert das
begann also mit meinem Versuch über
Elstern dieses elektronische Steuer
Dings da nach drei Stunden aufgegeben
noch mal dann habe ich mich für die
Papierform entschieden und dann mit
diesem ganzen Formularen sich
eingearbeitet ich empfehle immer
Papierform weil da kann man dann haben
die Finanzbeamten nach viel zu tun die
haben zum Lesen zu blättern und dann
kann man denen auch Fußnoten
reinschreiben dann können die also lesen
was man Fußnoten Erläuterungen bei ist
da können sie keine Fußnoten das geht
nicht das nimmst ja nicht an also da
kann man doch schön reinschreiben das
kommt aber der Oberarm also die Fristen
sind ja schon verlängert worden von
Abgabe 30 September auf 31 Januar ich
kann nur sagen ich fordere eine weitere
Fristverlängerung weil die abgabequote
liegt derzeit so ich glaube und bei
ungefähr 50% nur wir haben jetzt nur
noch zwei Wochen der Oberhammer ist dass
der Bund mit seinen Grundstücken
der muss ja selber der Bund für seine
Grundstücke die bundesligenschaften auch
bei den länderfinanzbehörden diese
grundsteuererklärungen abgeben der Bund
selber gewährt sich eine Abgabefrist
nicht 31 Januar sondern 30 September
diesen Jahres mit der Begründung es sei
alles so kompliziert also das was den
betroffenen Bürgern Millionen von
Bürgern zumutet lässt du für sich selbst
nicht gelten das ist ein echter Skandal
und deswegen sage ich also was für den
Bund Recht ist das muss für die Bürger
billig sein ganz also bei aller
Wertschätzung auch für ihre Arbeit aber
der eigentliche Skandal ist ihr Vortrag
hier denn sie wissen sehr genau
sie brauchen Sie nicht wundern wenn sie
unter 5% fallen hier bei der bei der
Berliner Wahl
lassen Sie mal sachlich darüber sprechen
sachlich darüber sprechen
wenn wir über diese Frage reden dass sie
hier vortragen dann ist es eine Frage
erstens dass das durch ein Gericht
entschieden wurde hier neue
Grundlage herbeizuführen zweitens ist es
nicht zu lösen es ist doch keine Frage
die die ampelregierung betrifft sondern
ist eine Frage die durch ein Gericht
entschieden wurde
eine neue Bemessung so und deshalb macht
es ja keinen Sinn das zu einem
politischen Skandal Thema zu machen und
dass ich daran so auf zu reden sondern
die Frage ist wie kriegen das gelöst
wenn man über Jahre die Digitalisierung
versäumt hat in politischer
Verantwortung sich stolz auf die
Schultern klopf wie lange man im
Deutschen Bundestag Verantwortung hatte
und dann sich an dieser Stelle mit
diesen Fragen auseinandersetzt dann ist
es doch genau das was dazu führt das
Glaubwürdigkeit in die Politik verloren
geht weil wir an dieser Stelle jetzt ein
Thema abzuarbeiten haben was entschieden
wurde gerichtlich was auch durch eine
Koalition in der CDU und CSU beteiligt
waren und Verantwortung hatten gemeinsam
Regierung gebildet haben mit der SPD
entsprechend verabredet worden ist das
so umzusetzen das wird jetzt durch einen
Ministerium abgearbeitet aber doch
deshalb nicht so ja aber die
Digitalisierung stand doch still in
unserem Land in den letzten 16 Jahren da
muss doch jetzt erstmal richtig
Modernisierung reinkommen und deshalb
verlieren
Digitalisierung
der Digitalisierung ja aber und es ist
auch eine Frage dass wir ein
Gerichtsurteil dahinter haben ja klar
was machen
zurückgeschossen und Sie müssen
Christian Lindner verteidigen es geht
mir doch hier gar nicht um die Frage wer
im Augenblick Bundesfinanzminister ist
ich schätze Christen sondern es geht um
was grundsätzlich ist dahinter es geht
darum ja dass die Frage der
Digitalisierung die sie ja auch gerade
angesprochen haben hier das Stapel
Papier in die Kamera gehalten ist ja
etwas was über Jahre in unserem Land
versäumt worden ist da müssen wir doch
aber selbst wenn das alles digital ist
dann dann bleibt ja doch noch diese
Arbeit für die viele Bürger überhaupt
nicht genau deshalb gab es schon mal
eine Fristverlängerung und wenn das
nicht auch bei verlängerten Fristen was
machen denn ältere Leute riesen Thema
Fachkraft für Gesundheit und
sozialdienstleistungen und ich habe
viele ältere Leute in der Betreuung die
kommen mit ihrer Rente gerade so aus die
können hier Häuschen gerade irgendwie so
kriegen sie das über die Runden ja und
können nur existieren weil sie keine
Miete bezahlen müssen die können dazu
irgendeinem Steuerberaterin und können
den drei vier 500 € in werfen damit das
ausgefüllt wird ich glaube nicht dass
die natalisierung die Lösung das Problem
eventuell vielleicht auch die
Grundsteuer nicht bezahlt das bedeutet
die Frage der Digitalisierung ist gerade
angesprochen weil die Frage wie viel
Papier habe ich da eigentlich gerade vor
mir was muss ich da alles ausfüllen geht
das nicht einfacher sie haben es ja
gerade gesagt was funktioniert da gut
bei Elster und was nicht wie ist dieses
System aufgestellt ist eine Frage der
technischen
das dass man das andere ist dass das
politisch jetzt auf Grundlage eines
Gerichtsurteils neu verhandelt werden
musste was SPD CSU und CDU entsprechend
umgesetzt dafür verantwortlich und das
interessiert auch der Bürger nicht ich
will doch mir geht's dabei noch um einen
Punkt deswegen habe ich es vorhin so
gesagt ich sage das ist ja das ist eine
riesen Thema ist auch eine
Herausforderung deshalb wurden ja auf
Fristen verlängert ähm das was mich
dabei nur ärgert ist wenn Sie sich hier
hinsetzen bei aller Wertschätzung ich
war so freundlich ich habe gesagt auch
ernst gemeint dass sie das so zu einem
Skandal hochschieben weil wir müssen das
hintereinander kriegen ich habe gesagt
Moment Moment
sechs bis sieben Prozent
gehört ich wünsche Ihnen ja das hier
reinkommen der bürgerliche ordentliche
Anteile in Berlin auch andere Frage nein
ich sage es ist das Skandal dass der
Staat für sich selber sonderfristen
einräumt und den normalen Bürgern die
die Zügel anlegt aber bitte natürlich
Digitalisierung haben wir viel zu wenig
wenn das funktionieren würde dann
bräuchte es diese
Aufhebens gar nicht weil die
Ämter eigentlich sollte man überall
reinschreiben Daten liegen in ihrem Haus
vor Daten liegen in Ihrem Hause vor alle
Daten die man da rein schreibt liegen
eigentlich in den Finanzverwaltungen vor
die müssen nur richtig verknüpft werden
und weil die Verwaltungen eben mangels
Digitalisierung darum haben sie in dem
Punkt recht sage ich ja auch man muss
Digitalisierung ist das nicht möglich
diese Verknüpfung aber diese Last dann
bei den Bürgern abzuladen alte Menschen
die kommen zu mir auch ins Abgeordneten
bitte helfen sie mir wir hatten
müssen doch helfen und
sollten auch für die normalen Menschen
geben
frustverlängerung sowie der Bund bis
September und dann hat man noch mal ein
bisschen Zeit ich nehme das heute mal
als Thema mit
damals aber schnell geeinigt werden ganz
ganz messbare Ergebnisse ich möchte
trotzdem auch generell noch mal bei dem
Thema Steuern bleiben weil viele die
sich jetzt mit diesen Unterlagen gerade
herumschlagen fangen sich dennoch mein
Gott und die Steuer und schon wieder die
Steuer und da sind wir wieder bei dem
Thema dass die Mitte immer mehr das
Gefühl hat ich zahle umso mehr die
Taschen sind voll oder hält teuer die
steuerkassen es läuft doch eigentlich
super
das Problem mit Bürokratie der ja also
das vielleicht muss die Bürokratie auch
mal angeschoben werden damit sie etwas
besser läuft ja dieses weil sie gesagt
haben haben wir schon immer so gemacht
machen wir nicht mehr anders dass das
einfach nicht mehr geht ja und dass man
sich dann nicht auf seinem Sessel
ausruhen kann sondern genau die
Geschwindigkeit die eben jetzt auch
vorgelegt worden ist bei unseren
energienöten dass die auch in anderen
Bereichen erstmal das Ziel sein soll und
nichts anderes wir brauchen diesen
Modernisierung an vielen Stellen und das
ist zum Beispiel dafür wo er wo er
dringend notwendig ist und wo wir jetzt
nicht noch mehr Zeit verlieren dürfen ja
und sie sehen ja in anderen Ländern sie
können sich bisher überall anschauen
sind ja auch viel unterwegs gewesen
woanders geht es ja und dann stelle ich
mir natürlich mit meinen 39 Jahren und
wenig
politiklaufzeit bisher die Frage wieso
geht es da und bei uns nicht und geht
dem nach und sage Mensch ja das muss ne
positiv Beispiele in unserem Land
deshalb habe ich ja vorhin einmal so
plakativ gesagt bei LNG hat funktioniert
und die Geschwindigkeit muss auch die
Vorgabe sein ne was machen Sie jetzt mit
ihrem Antrag wenn die Unterlagen ist
alle eingereicht oder wie geht's jetzt
bei ihnen da weiter
bei mir
Abgabe fertig und unterschrieben liegt
alles bereit und wird demnächst abgelegt
die original unterwegs
Anleitungen entdeckt die ich an die
Verwaltung an geeigneter Stelle schon
weitergereicht habe zur Verbesserung ich
bin auch da sehr hilfreich und jetzt
müssen wir sogar noch an die Frage haben
müssen sagen wie schaffen wir bei den
zukünftigen Steuerfragen bei den die sie
jetzt ansprechen wenn es um die Frage
Grundsteuer wird wie können wir ein
grunderwerbsteuerfreibetrag in unserem
Land einführen für die selbst und erst
genutzte Immobilie die man erwirbt von 3
bis 400.000 Euro
Beispiele
Freibetrag ne ja ja Grunderwerbsteuer
also die Grundsatzfragen dahinter in der
in der Steuerpolitik die müssen wir
genauso angehen wie die Frage denn
mit Kosten Berlin glaube ich auch Gründe
werksteuer
6,5%, das könnten sie Benzin die
Regierung kommen gleich mal runtersetzen
auf das bayerische Niveau 3,5%
daran können Sie wissen das liegen bei
810%. in der Stadt die zu halbieren bei
der Frage der Grundsteuer
haben wir sogar gegenfinanziert im
Landeshaushalt und haben gesagt dann
wären wir auf dem Bundesdurchschnitt
werden noch nicht ganz bei Bayern aber
würden sehr nah rankommen und damit eine
Entlastung in der Breite im Übrigen für
jeden der in dieser Stadt in einem
Mietwohnung oder im Eigentum wohnt in
der Blauwale
fließt na klar ja also haben wir
vorgeschlagen in der Frage Steuerpolitik
sie sehen ich kann in Berlin nicht
wählen
[Gelächter]